The little mermaid lived at the bottom of the sea with her father, grandmother, and five sisters.
She was not like her sisters.
They were happy living in the sea.
The little mermaid was not happy.
But she could not leave the sea.
She had to wait until she was 15 years old.
At last, the little mermaid was 15 years old.
"Now, you can go up out of the sea," said her grandmother.
The little mermaid swam up out of the sea.
She saw a big ship, and she swam near it.
One of them was a young man.
He was a prince.
"He is very handsome," she thought.
"I want to meet him."
Then, suddenly a storm hit the ship.
The prince fell into the sea.
He could not swim.
"I must help the prince," thought the little mermaid.
She pulled him close to land and pushed him onto it.
Then, she swam away from the prince.
"He does not know I saved him," she thought.
She slowly swam back to the bottom of the sea.
"No," the little mermaid thought.
"I want to live with the prince."
"I will ask the sea witch for help."
"I will not help you for free," the sea witch said.
"I want your beautiful voice."
"I will turn your tail into legs."
"But if you do this, you will never live at the bottom of the sea with your family again."
"You will also die if the prince does not marry you."
The little mermaid really wanted to be with the prince, so she agreed.